check this out hahaha isn't that awesome
that is hydrodynamic levitation check it
out this Styrofoam ball is levitating on
this stream of water and it's doing so
in a very stable way the setup is so
stable you can play frisbee through it
which is weird to me because the water
is off to one side of the ball and that
doesn't seem to make any sense you can
block the water for a second and the
ball will still levitate have a look and
that cool
[Music]
how can it be stable like this how can
this be a stable configuration that is
what we're gonna explain this is my
friend Blake he is a toy inventor and he
actually came up with this and he
brought it to me and I was like that is
awesome there's some really cool physics
going on here juggling with water I
can't believe it will just allow you to
switch balls like that they can even hit
each other as they go down so how does
this effect work well a lot of people
might think of the hairdryer ping-pong
ball effect which works basically based
on Bernoulli's principle that's actually
what we're showing here we've brought
this stream down so it's going at a very
low velocity so it's pretty much laminar
flow and what you can see if you look at
the ball is it's entirely enclosed in
water so that water stream comes up goes
around the ball and just just with the
ping-pong ball if it moves to one side
of the stream it slows down the flow of
fluid and according to Bernoulli's
principle this increases the pressure
relative to the faster flowing fluid on
the other side so it pushes the ball
back into the middle that is what
provides the stability for this ball but
I think what we're seeing with the
bigger balls is something different this
is the largest Styrofoam ball I could
find so I don't expect it to work but
we're gonna give it a shot should I go
higher oh it's happening
that is incredible it's like got this
instability but it corrects it's
incredible you should see the way the
water is spiraling off there is awesome
[Music]
so I've been thinking a lot about the
physics that makes this possible what I
think is happening is as the stream
contacts the ball it pushes it up but it
also pushes the ball out away from the
stream so what I think is remarkable is
that the ball actually will stay there
it isn't in a stable configuration and
from looking at the high-speed footage
what I really think is going on is this
water is getting thrown over and down by
the ball and since the ball is putting a
force over and down on the water that
water is putting a force up and in on
the ball which keeps it right in that
stream because there's a bit of adhesion
between the water here and the styrofoam
starts to go a little slower that pulls
all that water over the ball and that's
the start of how you get the ball to
spin and how you get that sprayed down
on the right-hand side
which provides more lift and keeps
forcing the ball back into the stream
come on once the ball is levitating it
remains stable because if it drifts too
far into the stream that decreases the
flow of water around the ball reducing
the force pushing it into the stream and
if it drifts too far out that increases
the water flow over the ball increasing
the force pushing it back into the
stream that's what makes the equilibrium
position so stable any slight
perturbation creates a restoring force
that moves the ball back to equilibrium
the rotation I think is also nice
because that gives it that angular
momentum providing a little bit of
stability side by side that's not so
important for these balls but it
certainly is important for the disc if
you try to levitate a disc you need to
keep it in the right orientation ah yes
getting the discs to levitate is
significantly harder than the balls
because they have to maintain their
vertical orientation in order for this
to work even a slight breeze makes this
very difficult
[Music]
hey check though can you come in and get
it oh my goodness this is a clear
demonstration that that is not just
about the Bernoulli effect right it's
due to the rotation of the disk that
actually carries the water over and
sprays it down which pushes that back
into the stream that's amazing
not only is this an awesome experiment
it's also pretty fun to play around with
in the summer and it was invented by my
friend Blake they'll come over my
channel and a Vinci and I'll show you
how with the simple home depot run you
can build this in your own backyard
I'll put a link to that video right here
so if you want to make this go check it
out
[Music]